I just don't like chain restaurants how
they even start like who was at the
first Chili's this food's awful let's
make a thousand of them
I'm sure Carl senior ran a great
hamburger stand
but then Junior had to go Nationwide
[__] it all up
there is one restaurant they do enjoy
that's Waffle House
yeah yeah
a bunch of animals in the crowd I love
it it was awesome listen to this though
I just saw an internet the other day
some guy ran naked through a waffle
house and shot a bunch of people
how [__] up do you have to be
to be barefoot in a Waffle House
you see somebody Barefoot in the wild
house you get the [__] out of there
person has no will to live